I think that the wonderful thing that I
learned writing the book extreme you and
interviewing some of the most
extraordinarily successful people in the
world I mean everyone from Condoleezza
Rice to bode miller the downhill skier
mr. cartoon who's a tattoo artist I mean
I interviewed people from all walks of
life who have achieved incredible
success in very different areas and what
I found with all of them is that even
when they achieved success like what
most of us would consider the pinnacle I
mean an Olympic gold medal is about as
good as it gets right they would then
say okay I'm Restless to get more out of
myself and I want to break myself down
and take on the next challenge and that
to me was pretty spectacular to see it's
like for them success is not a goal it's
just an ongoing journey and every time
they achieve something they realize that
there's more of their own potential to
unlock so to be extreme you is to be
maximizing every aspect of your own
personal potential and that means really
understanding who you are what are your
unique gifts what are your audio sync
receives what are the funny things about
you what blows your hair back and makes
you feel amazing and also where are you
not as strong like weren't we suck what
if things don't work for you and then
when you understand that and then really
push yourself to maximize everything
that is great about you and play your
game on your own terms that's being
extremely it's incredibly fulfilling
because I think when you are playing to
your greatest strengths like we've all
had that experience when you're in a job
or in an environment that just makes you
thrive and you come into work every day
and you feel super confident and you
just can be yourself and that is what it
feels like and the polar opposite is
when you find yourself in an
organization that just doesn't sort of
fit with who you are and you're having
to edit yourself in and try you know not
to get into trouble or do things the
wrong way so it feels pretty amazing to
be extreme you and it also is generally
a place when you are kind of pushing
yourself outside your comfort zone like
you
have the confidence to take on bigger
challenges and things that you haven't
done because you know that you're
playing To Your Strengths so the first
thing I definitely say is it's about
what I call checking yourself out and
that means like really understanding
what you love and what your greater
skills are and it's funny like there's a
lot of media around there today saying
to young people you know find your
passion and then you'll be happy and I'm
like you can't do a Google search and
find your passion you actually have to
get out there and try stuff you know and
get in there and really try it do it
like experience all sorts of different
things because that's when you'll notice
where you really shine and frankly where
you suck I mean I personally can speak
about working in the sports industry
where I just was like a duck to water I
loved it compared to working in the
video game industry where I sucked I
mean I just didn't have anything in
common with the product the people that
chose to work there and the feelings of
being in those two different places
we're equally as important as each other
to help me refine what was the most
extreme version of where I would thrive
and I think everybody needs to get in
and experience the good and the bad to
help sort of refine your own filter the
reason I actually wrote this book in the
first place is I found myself in my late
30s I had finally finally achieved some
what society would consider successes in
my career I had led the turnaround of a
five billion dollar business as its
president which is obviously no small
feat and I started seeing you know
articles that were written that would
refer to me or my bio readout when I'm
giving a speech and I would say she did
this great thing she did that great
thing she lived this company she's being
called this in the media she's amazing
and I literally would sit there
squirming in my chair going oh my god no
one telling the truth because the truth
is I've had some really embarrassing
along the way and I think it's
important for young people to see that
those who become successful have had all
those moments of uncertain
all those moments of frankly averageness
I mean I was that classic B student
never made the top sports team never
made the quiet solos like never got
picked for anything but still managed to
go on learning and refining to figure
out where I would you know achieve my
personal success and I believe that that
path exists for absolutely everyone but
we have a culture of success right now
that would say otherwise like when you
combine the world of social media where
all of us are pictured you know putting
these perfectly coifed pictures into the
world and then you throw in the whole
you know 40 under 40 list 30 under 30
let's everyone in the world is
apparently crushing it except for you
like it's really hard to believe that
you can become great but yet I know from
my story that it was possible and then I
went on this like mission to interview
some really really successful people to
prove my case and I totally forgets
because what I found in the book and I
effectively codified it into a method of
how you get the best out of yourself was
that every successful person in the
world did not start knowing that they
were going to get there pretty much
every one of them did not start with
these natural god-given talents most of
them ended up succeeding in a field that
was completely different to what they
originally expected so it was a real
story of willingness to experience and
try things and then eventually figure
out where you're going to thrive and I
think the last lesson and all of it was
that even those experiences early on
where you feel like you've put X number
of years into the wrong career or the
right you're going in the wrong
direction
even when you change directions those
early experiences actually contribute to
what becomes a great success so nothing
is wasted
you